America which is a marvelous idea a
unique idea fantastic idea
I'm extremely primeira can but America
has ceased to exist
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking to international man
of investment financial guru and
visionary Doug Casey he is the author
most recently with Luis James of right
on the money a great book of collected
conversations about all sorts of money
and life issues and he also has put
together a great documentary called
meltdown which you can get at his
website will show you where you can get
that on the screen Doug thanks for
talking to Reason was your Nick ok
meltdown you're a half-hour documentary
that's available online it is talking
about how unfunded liabilities excessive
government spending are basically
bringing the u.s. to the brink of some
kind of economic catastrophe you talk
about how failing to address challenges
before they become full-blown
catastrophes are a problem what's what
what is the what is the challenge that
we need to face up to in the US well
there are so many frankly it seems to me
that the US has been going downhill in
all-important regards for many years
it's just a question when we pick our
start point but at this point I would
say socially definitely financially
definitely economically politically its
problems all the way around so where's
good and that's that's we're asking in
this and and you know what one of the
things that's interesting is you walk
through three examples of failed States
Yugoslavia Argentina and Zimbabwe let's
look a little bit of talk a little bit
about the lessons they hold for
contemporary America in Yugoslavia you
in that section to talk about how
political tensions the collapse of the
Soviet Union and cheap Western loans
that were propping up Yugoslavia is a
kind of counter to the Warsaw Pact
nations led to rampant inflation what
what happens when inflation gets out of
control people become very unhappy with
each other with their neighbors and the
government of course is looking for
somebody to blame for the problems it's
caused and on an international basis
that's warfare and of course Yugoslavia
was
just an artificial compound of five or
six different countries which all flew
apart now I'm not saying that what's
going to have what happened in
Yugoslavia is gonna happen in the US but
then again on the other hand
increasingly the u.s. is sectional izing
where people that live in echo topia in
the Pacific Northwest don't have an
awful lot in common with the people in
southern Florida so I think centripetal
force is overtaking the US so that's so
we might see I've got well I guess the
term is called balkanization for a
reason right that I mean we're sections
pull apart and have less and less to do
with each other and that breeds
hostility on the one hand the hostility
is bad but on the other hand it's a good
thing because my ideal political
scenario for the world is to have 7
billion little nation-states not 225 so
if the u.s. broke up into six more or
less I think that would be a good thing
Argentina is one of the countries you
spent a lot of time in Argentina and you
know it's always something that is
refreshing or it reminds you how
Argentina was once the one of the big
big countries in the world economy and
certainly in South America and the
Western Hemisphere at one point I think
you you or somebody else in the film
says it's been run by idiots
for a very long time talk a little bit
about that yes I would say we could go
beyond saying idiots we could the
present time it's being run by the
criminally insane now that's the bad
news but there's always good news about
these things and just as in the United
States which is going to have very very
serious problems extremely serious
problems if you look at Argentina the
culture is fantastic the standard of
living is still fantastic if you have
money from abroad although the
government is totally dysfunctional so
these are two different things that
people get confused people are afraid to
come to Argentina because they hear how
crazy the government is but when you're
there the government doesn't bother you
at all they're mainly interested in
stealing so you know there's a lesson to
be had there
you you know Argentina defaulted on its
debt good thing in my opinion yeah yeah
and that's a good thing but did that
increase political instability well to
start with Nick I'm very happy they
defaulted on their debt because it just
means that that was a hundred billion
dollars that the next generations are
not going to have to pay off to whoever
idiotic enough to lend the government
all that money but um there were a lot
of consequences within society when that
happened I mean the currency was
destroyed so all the people that were
prudent and put aside money in either
pesos or dollars just took the dollars
and turned him into pesos and that
devoured is typical well and you talked
about being at at one point during the
worst of the Argentine financial crisis
you were at the Four Seasons Hotel and
you could not break a hundred dollar
bill I had flown in and I didn't have
any local money and at the time they had
lots of different types of local money
because all the provinces were issuing
their own money to have some kind of a
medium exchange and you know it's the
Four Seasons for God's sake and smallest
I had was a US hundred they couldn't
break it it was very inconvenient how am
I gonna get a cab in the street I didn't
have any pesos or Patagonia or any of
these things to give the guy so anything
could happen and if it happens here in
the US is gonna be much much more
serious than in Argentina because the
u.s. dollars the world reserve currency
and there's who knows a trillion of the
things outside of the US and at some
point if confidence is lost
internationally all those dollars that
are now abroad are going to come back in
here to buy titles to properties to
corporations we Boeing's and the money
supply will explode and it could be
catastrophic the third country that you
look at is in Bob way in two thousand
Robert Mugabe started an expert
land for mostly white farmers but
basically took a country that had been
one of the bread baskets of Africa had
been relatively productive and just
turned it into a nightmare both kind of
in terms of state sanctioned violence as
well as economic catastrophe you know
what is there anything that can be done
to a place like Zimbabwe now that it is
so far along in this kind of ongoing
catastrophe well this we talked about
earlier my hobby is talking to the
people that run these backward little
countries and trying to propose
something ultra radical to reform their
reputations and so forth so well I'd say
the chances of a renaissance in Zimbabwe
are actually better than the chances of
a renaissance in the u.s. now of course
they're not comparable because Imbaba is
absolutely at the bottom of the barrel
and we have an immense amount of saved
up capital here in the US so our
standard of living is still very high
although it's clearly dropping rapidly
for the average middle-class person but
sure there's always something that can
be done but I'd say the chances of a
real improvement here in the US are
small well let's talk about that because
in the final section of the documentary
meltdown you you say we're at the edge
of the precipice and you know we're debt
persistent deficits government spending
devaluation of the currency through you
know massive stimulus whether it's
monetary or fiscal you know in many ways
you say that we're in a worse shape than
we were in 2007 as the recession was
kicking in and the financial global
financial crisis was happening how are
we worse off than we were then well the
people that are running the US
government believe that by pulling
monetary and fiscal levers that they can
get the American economic machine to do
what they'd like and of course this is a
ridiculous conceit and to save the
country from a massive depression
starting in 2007 they've been printing
up trillions trillions of currency units
now we're of those units going they've
all gone to financial institutions banks
insurance companies brokerage firms to
keep them from failing and they
basically stayed there so about 4 or 5
trillion new dollars have been created
but they're not circulating in society
they're sitting with those financial
institutions and from your perspective
that would explain why we don't have
rampant inflation exactly as this money
has been created but it hasn't been
released into the general population
exactly because they they don't want to
I mean what are they going to do with
this this money I mean where's all the
money going it's why the stock market is
at an all-time high it's why the bond
market isn't probably the biggest
financial bubble in all of history
because of these things but at the same
time people are not terribly interested
in investing in plant and new businesses
it's hard from a regulatory point of
view and it's very iffy from an economic
point of view and this is very serious
from the point of view of the government
planners because we've shot their arrow
what are they going to do when the
economy starts heading downhill again
whether it's the end of this year or I
think certainly next year what are they
going to print up this time 10 20 30
trillion dollars of new currency at that
point the dollar really will become a
hot potato the foreigners will start
dumping it Americans I mean they say
inflation in the US right now is what a
1 or 2 percent this is completely
ridiculous now why do you say that
because if you watch yourself and keep
your own consumer price index you can
see prices actually are going up right
now even now in between 5 and 10 percent
per year everything from the food you
buy and stores to the meals you eat in
restaurants
these things have been disguised in
other words the the Americans are taking
a lesson from the Argentine's which is
one thing we try to point out in that
video where the Argentine government
Sasol we only have inflation of eight or
ten percent well it's actually 30
percent but their figures say eight to
ten percent and it's the same thing in
this country just you talk about you
know foreigners dumping American
currency or American debt selling it off
or calling it in the in the documentary
you talk a bit about how China and
Russia have been talking about you know
where Russia rather has been courting
China which owns about one in 1.2 1.5
billion dollars the trillion dollars of
of our public debt to say like hey why
don't you you know let's team up and
screw the Americans is that a likely
scenario for a country like China given
that its economy depends so much on
America it's extremely likely because
why with the Russians and the Chinese
who have no reason to like or trust the
US government why would they want to
hold there are the unsecured liabilities
of the US government which could be
defaulted on and they could be stuck
with it this is why the Russians and the
Chinese even according to the figures
they disclose been buying a huge amounts
of gold over the last five or ten years
and I think what's going to happen is
that you're going to have a gold-backed
ruble a gold back one and that will
start circulating slowly at first
internationally and people will trust
them more than the dollar well this goes
to you know it's interesting because
that your documentary is is interesting
it's a great history lesson it's it's
disturbing it's alarmist and then but
towards the end you say you know what
there's kind of like these things never
change
all what one of the things that you
strive to show and I think succeed at is
that all of these problems are political
in nature that they're not you know
they're not rooted in economics it's
politicians kind of gym or you know
jimmying the economic system in various
ways like you were talking about before
and your advice is not to you know elect
small government you know a limited
government enthusiast president or
anything but it's to internationalize
your portfolio and diversify your
political risk talk a little bit about
that
right I wouldn't waste time trying to
turn around a supertanker that is what
the US government amounts to you're
doomed failure and perhaps being
squashed by the super tanker in in the
process much better that you look to
save your own assets and since the
problem is political in nature you have
to diversify politically and it's a big
world out there the u.s. is only 4% of
the world's population and all the real
growth in the world is going to be
happening abroad
I mean I'm particularly interested in
Africa at this point which I I know but
most people will think is crazy and
they're not interested in but in 25
years we'll leave it on this point a lot
of people particularly conservatives but
also liberals and libertarians worry
about the end of American exceptionalism
you know where America is not just a
unique country but the leading country
in the world do you do you care about
that well look we have to make a
distinction here one is America which is
a marvelous idea a unique idea a
fantastic idea
I'm extremely primeira can but America
has ceased to exist it's been replaced
by the United States which is just
another of 225 nation states that covers
the face of the earth like a skin
disease at this point so we ought to
make that distinction people shouldn't
conflate these two things the ideal with
the political reality so what you've got
to do is get a lot of your assets out of
the control of the government that
thinks it owns you because it's gonna
it's treating you like a milk cow now
and as what happened in Zimbabwe and
Yugoslavia shows if they think they need
to they'll treat you like a beef cow
okay well we'll leave it there Doug
Casey the most recent book is right on
the money and the new documentary which
is available online is
down thanks so much for talking to
Reason TV Thank You Nick for a reason TV
I'm Nick Gillespie